it is my honor to present the nominees
for outstanding performance by an
actress in a leading role and a part of
that presentation is a short look at the
careers of those actresses the nominees
are Jill Clayburgh
her screen work has encompassed a wide
range of roles from the early port noise
complaint
terminal man the biographical gable and
Lombard the comedies Silver Streak and
semi tough and her unforgettable
performance as an unmarried woman this
year she is nominated for her warm and
loving work in starting over Sally Field
I'm just a few strong film roles she has
etched a character of a gutsy and
outrageous yet always loving kind of
woman energetic and principled and
capable of the strongest kind of loyalty
we've enjoyed her and stay hungry Smokey
and the Bandit heroes the end Cooper and
especially in her performance this year
as Norma Rae Jane Fonda
personally and compromising in its depth
and quality it has encompassed films
like they shoot horses don't they cap
Balu barefoot in the park Clute Giulia
last year's powerful drama coming home
and now the role of the dedicated
reporter in the film that may be the
most prophetic of this year or any other
year the China Syndrome Marsha Mason
she has brought humor and humanity to
every role she has played beginning with
bloom in love and the remarkable
Cinderella Liberty these performances
were followed need I mentioned by the
goodbye girl the cheap detective the
moving and emotional promises in the
dark and finally the role for which she
is nominated this year Chapter two Bette
Midler
presents that occasional phenomena of
our industry a first major film
performance of a dazzling strength that
shows in every frame the years of
experience that preceded it
she has already conquered the worlds of
theater concert in cabaret and the same
charisma shines in the part for which
she is nominated tonight the Rose
I'm not gonna do and the winner is Sally
Field
oh I'm gonna be the one to cry tonight
I'll tell you right now they said this
couldn't be done Norma Rae was a real
gift to me it was given to me by laddie
and Jay and Gareth the old Fox
it was given to me was given to me by
Alex rose and tomorrow as Sayyaf who
fought very hard to get it made it was
given to me by Irving Ravich and Harriet
Frank jr. and it truly was a gift every
single word was given to me by John
Alonzo followed me around with a camera
and never hope to shine himself just
gave it all to me it was given to me by
the actors especially Beau Bridges and
rod Liebman whose real craft and talent
and love and support is why I'm here and
mostly it was given to me because of
Marty RIT
Marty red is Norma Rae he has fought all
his life to put on films that are
courageous that say things that are part
of him that he feels should be said that
have the box-office potential of 75
cents sometimes less and I thank him for
that he's taught me a lot and the best
gift that Marty gave me was that he let
me feel all the time that I was doing it
myself and I know that I didn't and on a
personal note I'd like to thank my
mother and my sister for holding me
together and just Plano holding me and
my kids Peter and Eli for being my
constant inspiration and no matter how
many boards I win if it weren't for them
I wouldn't be worth a damn thank you
very much
you